I think there is an element of truth in
that which the mega preachers dope that
what we call the pastor preneur they
don't they don't particularly like that
aspect but it has to be said and in a
Rick Warren's a very good test case of
this is actually you look at some of the
messages they're delivering amongst this
sort of cuddlier nicer thing you know
there's still quite hard line on issues
like abortion gay marriage famously I
mean Warren got into trouble with a lot
of people but prior to his his he's a
gig at the Obama inauguration you know
that that I think you know that was a
maybe in a surprise some people around
him that he was suddenly seen as more
intolerant of quote-unquote for me
cousin and people imagined in the end a
lot of them if you listen what they
actually teach it's not quite far and
brimstone but you know it's got a quite
stern message underneath it so I think
there is that militating against it